[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new henry cavill
superman video as you can see keeping
himself very busy building new superhero
gaming pcs there's a bunch of funny
stories that henry cavill tells about
being a hardcore gamer he is very open
about being a hardcore nerd there's also
some dc movie news and justice league
stuff that's going on that i'll add to
the end of the video too so we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we'll do a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know where you
want superman's first cameo to be in the
new dc movies i'll just number these as
we go along just to stay organized but
if you guys couldn't tell first cool
easter egg the blue tank top that he's
wearing there while he's building this
is actually the exact same one that he
was wearing during the justice league
snyder cut live stream he did with zack
snyder back in may when they announced
that they were doing the snyder cut so
i'm assuming that this video is actually
pretty old and he's just posting it
right now he just posted it to his
social like hey this is what i was doing
during the quarantine playing a ton of
video games zack snyder was doing that
big live stream rewatch of the man of
steel movie doing a live commentary with
a bunch of cool behind-the-scenes easter
eggs and details and at the end of it
henry cavill popped in in his blue tank
top to do a giant zoom call in the
formal announcement that they were doing
the justice league snyder cut like hey i
think you should totally release it and
then boom they're releasing it then
people took all these screen caps of
henry cavill in this video and turned it
into a bunch of gaming memes like henry
cavill with all his facial hair in the
tank top doing minecraft let's plays way
back when they streamed this i joked
that this should be one of the next
superman cameos in the flash flashpoint
movie like ezra miller's flash has that
giant video wall with all the screens in
the background they should just insert
some of these henry cavill gaming memes
in the background on one of the screens
and not call any attention to it or ever
mention it during the movie for those of
you wondering what he's gaming on here
this is obviously an amd system i don't
think he's doing any kind of integration
or anything like that usually pc
builders like this don't pay big time
money for people like henry cavill to do
ads for them usually you just see other
tech youtubers doing stuff like this but
for those of you wondering what other
kinds of gaming he does for the most
part he said that he is firmly team pc
master race there was a big witcher
netflix interview that he did last year
where he disses the hell out of consoles
in favor of playing games on pcs so i'm
assuming he's not going to be a big ps5
or xbox series x fan
playstation or xbox pc oh wow yeah
you're a pc gamer yeah
but was that from when you were young or
yes yeah my dad got me into that when i
was um very very young did you kind of
build your own gaming pc um i have not
quite ventured into building my own
myself i've definitely have i have had
custom pcs over the years um that will
be the next the next project as soon as
i find enough time you could tell this
interview was happening last year
because he said i haven't built my own
custom pc i'm just waiting to have the
time for that to be my next project
turns out he found himself with a ton of
extra time during the quarantine i think
when he was doing that interview though
talking about how pcs were so much
better than consoles he was mostly also
talking about the witcher 3 but my
favorite henry cavill gaming story is
actually a superman man of steel story
that goes way back so back when zack
snyder first decided to cast henry
cavill around 2011 this is actually him
wearing christopher reeve's superman
costume by the way way way back before
man of steel zack snyder called henry
cavill himself to tell him he was going
to become the next superman it's a huge
deal to play such an iconic character so
of course zack snyder wanted to call him
himself and tell him the good news but
the way henry cavill tells the story he
missed zack snyder's call saying that he
got the part because he was too busy
playing world of warcraft he wasn't
addicted to gaming or anything like that
it wasn't like a huge legit problem it
was just a coincidence that he missed
the call but after he finished playing
that day he saw the missed call had a
major heart attack and then started
calling his agent and calling zack
snyder back to thank him profusely well
the first time i got the call i
actually missed it i was
i was playing world of warcraft at the
time and
i had my priorities straight
wait a minute you were home it's not
like you weren't home you were home but
you were playing world of warcraft and
the phone rings and you're like i'll get
that later i'll get yeah yeah absolutely
i'll get that later and i was playing uh
it was an important part of a particular
dungeon that i was going through
and
it's cool now that i'm superman yeah
henry cavill hasn't really stopped
playing video games or anything like
that he mostly just does his hardcore
gaming when he's in between movies or
filming the witcher 2020 has just been a
really weird case where everyone in
hollywood was just stuck waiting doing
nothing for several months before they
could go back to filming new movies and
tv shows thus the quarantine superman
gaming pc so henry cavill playing a ton
of video games while he's busy also
trying to convince warner brothers to do
another superman man of steel movie so
we'll probably get more news about that
at the dc fandom comic con event in
august zack snyder is also going to be
dropping the justice league snyder cut
trailer during that two the big proper
trailer they're doing panels for all the
big dc movies all the big tv shows and
even some of the hbo tv shows they're
working on the big budget ones like they
just announced the batman hbo tv series
they have the green lantern hbo tv
series whatever big trailers they drop
of course i'll do a video for it i'm
sure marvel will do the same thing later
there's a big comic con at home event
happening next week too so i'll do any
big trailer videos that drop during that
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them in terms of
other big superman movies they actually
just released a new dc animated superman
man of tomorrow movie but it's a
completely new animation style from the
previous dc animated universe the other
big news you probably just saw is they
announced more characters from the
justice society for the black adam movie
so i'll probably do a video for that
later today that video should post later
tonight if i can finish it fast enough
everyone click here for the new justice
league snyder cut trailer and click here
for that new netflix umbrella academy
season 2 trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe i'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]
you